Voiceover:Let's say that
we've got a position vector, P
and it is equal to or
represented as a column vector,
right over here, 2, 1.
If we wanted to plot this,
and that is what I'll do.
Let's plot it.
If we were to plot it,
that's my Y axis,
this right over here is my X axis.
If we assume that the first entry
here is X coordinate, 1, 2, 1.
Our position vector is
going to be right over here.
We could represent it.
We could represent it in
this kind of vector symbol, like that.
Where the tail is at the origin
and the tip, the head, is at that point
or we could say it's really
representing this position,
right over here on the coordinate plan.
What I wanted to do in this video
is apply a transformation
to this position vector.
The way I'm going to do it
is I'm going to multiply our vector, P
by a matrix and then the resulting product
is going to give me
another position vector.
So, what do I mean by that?
I could have a transformation
matrix, capital T
and let's just say it is
equal to 2, 1, -1, and 2.
What happens if I multiply TxP?
Let's do that right over here.
TxP, so first let's just make sure that
this is actually a valid operation
that matrix multiplication
or matrix vector
multiplication is defined here.
Let's just look at what T and P look like.
I'm gonna copy and paste.
That is T and this is P right over here.
Can we multiply a 2x2 matrix
times a column vector like this,
which is essentially 2x1 matrix.
Well sure, as as we know
matrix multiplication is only defined,
or at least conventional
matrix multiplication
is only defined if the first matrix number
of columns is equal to the number
of rows in the second
matrix, right over here.
We see there, both of those are 2.
This is going to result in a 2x1 matrix.
What's interesting about that is
that this is another column vector.
This is another position vector.
You took this vector P,
multiplied it by this
transformation vector
and we're gonna get another 2x1,
which we could think of
as a position vector,
which we could plot.
What's essentially happened is
this transformation vector has moved,
has essentially given this point.
It has given us a new point.
Let's think about what that is.
This first entry here,
we're essentially thinking about,
we're going to deal with the first row
and the first and the only column, really.
Let me do, use a color
that I haven't used yet.
We're gonna think about
this row and this column.
It's gonna be 2x2, which is 4,
plus 1x1, which is 1
or this is just going to be equal to 5.
For the second entry, right over here.
It's going for the
second row, first column.
It's gonna deal with the second row here
and the one and only
column, right over here.
-1x2 is -2, plus 2x1, which is 2.
-2+2 is just equal to 0.
Now, we have the position 5, 0,
which is right over here.
1,2,3,4,5
So, we started with this point,
this position vector, I
guess you could say, P
As transformed it to this
other position vector
and I guess we could call this P prime.
If you wanted to draw them as vectors,
this right over, kinda
tradition vector form,
that right over there is P prime
and this right over here is P.
This right over here is P.
This is P actually, let me
make sure there's a prime.
This is P prime
and the way we got from P to P prime
is using this transformation matrix.